let's keep going with our 2008 Calculus
BC Free answer question so we're on
problem number two and I cut and pasted
the table that they gave in the problem
and I'll read the rest of the problem
and let's see what we can do
so it says concert tickets went on sale
at noon T equals zero and we're sold out
within nine hours the number of people
waiting in line to purchase tickets at
time T is modeled by a twice
differentiable function l l of T so this
is the number of people waiting in line
at any time and I think this isn't you
know I guess this is noon 12:00 noon
1:00 p.m. 9:00 p.m. so all the tickets
are sold by 9:00 p.m. and they tell us
it's twice differentiable so that means
that whatever function were modeling
this is LF T that the that it's
continuous because it's it's
differentiable and it since it's twice
differentiable we also know that it's
derivative is continuous right because
the second derivative exists at all
points anyway so it says part a let me
make sure I'm not writing too thickly
part a use the data in the table to
estimate the rate let me actually just
copy and paste this I've just figured
out how to do this so I figure it
doesn't hurt okay if I can paste it edit
paste there you go you probably you
probably can't read it but all it says
use the data in the table to estimate
the rate at which the number of people
waiting in line was changing at 5:30
p.m. so they don't give us any data on
5:30 p.m. they give us 4 p.m. and 7:00
p.m. or T equals 5 point 5 right show
the computations that lead to your
answer indicate the units of measure so
what do they want to know they want to
know the rate at which an estimate of
the rate at which the number of people
waiting in line was changing so they
don't give us they don't give us a you
know a continuous function definition
they just give us a bunch of sample
points of this function L of T so the
best estimate I can do of the rate at
which that this L of T is changing at
time 5 point 5 and 5 point 5 is in
between the
is to just figure out the average rate
of change between time for and times 7
so how do we figure out well the average
rate of change is just the slope so
let's write it so what's the slope so we
can write you know average rate of
change or Delta Delta L over delta T at
five point five you can write it however
you want however you think that the exam
graders would best like to see it we
could say it at time five point five we
could say approximately equals or
whatever but it's just going to be the
slope between these two points so it's
lo7 L of seven minus L of 4 all of that
over seven over four rise over run or
change in the value of the function
divided by change in the independent
variable L of seven is 154 they give us
that LF or is 126 126 and we divided by
seven minus four so that equals what 54
minus 126 is 20 let's see if I have 24
24 plus 26 is 50 so it's equal to 28
right 28 right if this was 2 less it
would be 30 here it says 28 and 7 minus
4 is 3 so you could say that the average
rate of change is 28 over 3 or you could
write that as 9 and 1 thirds and they
want us to use the units of measure
indicates units of measure
so the numerator this is people right
people people and what's the denominator
it's hours people per hour so my best
estimate or our best estimate of the
rate at which the number of people
waiting in line was changing at 5:30
p.m. which is between these two points
is the average slope between these two
points which is nine and one third
people per hour
that's it let's do Part B let me clear
all of this
so we have enough space for Part B and
I'll copy and paste I don't know if you
can read it but it's maybe you can so it
doesn't hurt to just copy and paste
let's edit paste move it down okay Part
B says use a trapezoidal sum with three
sub intervals maybe I can make this a
little bit bigger let me see if I can
grow that a little bit I don't want to
take up all the space though no that's
not doesn't look good it tastes ok well
I'll read it out loud in case you can't
see it use a trapezoidal sum with three
sub intervals to estimate the average
number of people waiting in line during
the first four hours of the ticket or on
sale if you want to do this really fast
you wouldn't have to graph it but I'm
about to graph it because I want you to
understand how to do this problem if you
understand it you don't have to graph it
so let's graph some of these points and
we really just have to do the first four
hours because actually let's graph all
of them just because it might might be
useful for in future parts of the
problem and if you weren't graphing it
while recording a video would probably
be a little bit faster let's see that
should be good enough and what are our
data points if you have let's see one
two three four five six seven eight nine
you don't have to do it so neatly well
it's good to do it neatly when you're
doing the exam because otherwise you'll
confuse yourself and let's see how high
what's how high should my y-values get
or my L values this is time right here
this is my L of T axis well it goes up
to about let's see 176 is the high point
at least on the data we have so let's
say this is 1 let's say this is 200 200
so halfway up would be let's see this
would be 100 this would be
150 this would be 50 I don't know what
that sound was from but let's keep going
forward so let's let's plot the points
at T equals zero they're 120 people in
line that's about right there
at T equals 156 and we're just
approximating it's about right there at
T equals 3 they skipped 2 at T equals
threes 176 people in line so that's
going to be right about there just
approximating it T equals 4 we have a
hundred and 26 people in line it's a
little bit more than at T equals zero
126 people in line T equals seven we
have 150 people in line it's right about
there
and T equals 8 we have 80 that's a
little bit of a little ride right there
and T equals 9 everyone the line is gone
everyone has gotten their tickets or
maybe they got sold out and let's
connect those points connect the dots so
from here to there and from there to
there there to there
there to there almost time okay so we've
at least plotted the sample points and
connected them with lines we know that
the real L of T whatever we used to
approximate it it's not going to have
these sharp edges because it's
differentiable it's actually twice
differentiable so it's actually going to
be a smoother curve right because we can
take the derivative any point if this
was the actual function you would be
able to take a derivative at this point
because there it just goes from you know
there's a positive slope here that it
because immediately switches to a
negative slope like the absolute value
function so you actually wouldn't be
able to take the derivative at that
point but anyway back to the problem use
a trapezoidal sub with three sub
intervals to estimate the average number
of people waiting in line during the
first four hours so the first four hours
that's right here now this might seem
kind of daunting a trapezoidal sum for
the fourth actually I just realized that
I'm for some reason I YouTube used to
let me do longer videos because I
thought I was a partner but now for some
reason it's been limiting me again so I
will continue Part B in the next video
see you soon